what is going on everybody welcome back
to the channel I'm your host Warren
Thompson and today is one of the best
days ever I'm sure everybody has heard
by now and if you haven't I am happy to
be the first one to tell you Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman have confirmed
that Hugh Jackman is returning as
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. we are getting
Wolverine in the MCU and it is the one
and only Hugh Jackman's Wolverine this
is incredible I know everybody is losing
their minds right now a lot of people
did not want a new Wolverine in the MCU
so it's just amazing that we are getting
Hugh Jackman The Wolverine in the MCU
but in a movie with one of his best
friends Ryan Reynolds Deadpool I mean
this is what we all dreamed of we never
actually saw it in a Deadpool film we
don't count that X-Men Origins Wolverine
film I mean I'm just on cloud nine right
now I'm sure everybody else is and the
best part is that it came from Ryan
Reynolds it came from this video that
Ryan Reynolds released here it is if you
haven't seen it and if you have watch it
again here we go hey everyone uh we're
extremely sad to have missed d23 but
we've been working very hard on the next
Deadpool film for uh a good long while
now
I've had to really search my soul on
this one uh his first appearance in the
MCU obviously needs to feel special we
need to stay true to the character find
new depth and motivation new meaning
every Deadpool needs to stand out and
stand apart it's been an incredible
challenge that has forced me to reach
down deep inside and I
yeah
completely
empty up here
and terrifying but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
I love how they did this I love how
casual they made it because everybody
knows they know that it's a huge deal
that this is some of the biggest news of
all time to us Marvel fans and I know it
means a ton to both Ryan Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman has actually
stated plenty of times that he wish he
could have been a part of the MCU that
is his regret not being a part of the
Avengers interacting with them being in
the universe where everything is
connected now Hugh Jackman actually gets
to live that he gets to have no regrets
when he finally does hang up that mantle
of Wolverine but it is not happening
today as we get Deadpool 3 September 6th
of
2024 and just as we suspected we were
all thinking Deadpool 3 could be that
first film to kick off phase six and now
it is unless this film does not take the
fall of 2024 Untitled slot which I'm
sure it does but if it doesn't then
there's going to be enough other film
but I'm pretty sure it does so Deadpool
3 is going to kick off phase six of the
MCU and what a way to kick off that
phase with Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine now here's a big
question a lot of people have already
been asking the question of is Hugh
Jackman going to permanently be playing
Wolverine in the MCU and of course I
cannot speak for Hugh Jackman and we do
not know the answer however if I were to
guess and I really hope for this I would
assume that he is going to be playing
Wolverine until Secret Wars I think this
might actually confirm kind of a big
X-Men rumor report that has been going
around the report was that Deadpool was
going to be coming to the MCU of course
he's coming from the fox universe but
the rumor and Report was that he's going
to be bringing some X-Men with him well
they did just confirm that he is going
to be bringing at least one major X-Men
with him to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Wolverine and this kind of
backs up the theory that I had before
that Marvel Studio is not going to
really get fully into the new MCU
mutants the new characters that are
going to be coming until after Secret
Wars they're going to dive into it a
little bit before and during Secret Wars
but I don't think we're getting our
actual X-Men team with the new
characters until phase seven which I'm
fine with honestly I'm so excited right
now I don't need any X-Men in the MC
until phase seven because we have Hugh
Jackman coming to the MCU in phase six I
mean this is the dream what I love about
this video that Ryan Reynolds released
is that it's true Ryan Reynolds style
you can tell that he's obviously being
funny and he's being sarcastic but also
it's actually very genuine because we
know that Ryan Reynolds himself
personally has been working on the
script for about three years now maybe
even more and he actually stresses in
this video that it's going to be his
first appearance in the MCU it needs to
be special and then he says that each
Deadpool film needs to stand on its own
he says it needs to stand out and stand
apart and as he says that of course and
true Ryan Reynolds fashion as he says
that he's pouring a drink of Aviation
gin the Gin Company that he owns into a
Deadpool mug love him so much Shameless
advertising and I love it but he says
that it forced him to reach down deep
inside and we see him sitting on the
toilet reading what I assume is probably
a Deadpool comic I can't really make it
out it's not very clear but if I know
Ryan Reynolds that is probably a
Deadpool comic and we see him in a suit
that could be a new suit but also kind
of looks like the suit from Deadpool 2.
it probably is the suit from Deadpool 2
because Deadpool 3 hasn't started
filming yet so no huge reveal here but I
just love here how Ryan Reynolds is
talking about all this soul searching to
make Deadpool 3 a standout film and for
it to be amazing and it's now in the MCU
and then he says and I've got nothing so
he almost makes it not like a cheap shot
but he almost makes it like a cop out
like yeah let's just throw Wolverine in
there that's what everybody wants that's
what's gonna make this movie absolutely
incredible everybody's gonna talk about
this forever it's going to be the best
thing and he plays it off like it's this
easy move like hey yeah let me just get
my best friend Hugh Jackman who plays
Wolverine to pick up the mantle again
look he's right there in the background
we're chilling at the same house right
now it's no big deal at all I love how
he does that and I love how people have
been asking Hugh Jackman for years if he
would come back as Wolverine and he's
been saying no he's been saying that
he's done he's put that character to the
side him and Patrick Stewart actually
said the same thing about their
characters they said in Logan they both
said goodbye to their characters when
their characters died in Logan that was
it for them they said bye and they
didn't want to do anything else because
they didn't want to undo that story arc
for their characters however we are now
in the Multiverse and a lot is possible
we just saw Professor Xavier played by
Patrick Stewart and Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness and of course
it was a different Patrick Stewart so it
didn't undo anything now the only
question is which timeline is this Hugh
Jackman going to be taken from it seemed
like the timeline that Deadpool was in
in Deadpool 2 you since he was at the X
mansion with the X-Men who will call the
First Class X-Men depending on how the
timeline kind of works in the fox
Universe however you want to follow it
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine could actually
be alive at that time so maybe it is
going to be pretty similar to the Hugh
Jackman that we known that we've seen
throughout all of the X-Men films from
Fox and again he's gonna be in Deadpool
3 but I would not be surprised in the
slightest if he stuck around for
Avengers Secret Wars and we saw him and
some variants of him and maybe some
other actors playing Wolverine as well
maybe the new Wolverine however I don't
really think they're going to introduce
a new Wolverine for a while and that's
why I kind of think that this move is
pretty brilliant and everybody at Marvel
Studios was probably really on board
because Hugh Jackman is Iconic as
Wolverine we all know that so replacing
him is going to be incredibly hard they
probably don't want to do that for a
while so just have him come back and be
in a movie with his best friend Ryan
Reynolds it's it's so perfect it's so
exciting I'm just on Cloud9 right now
I'm sure you all are as well but let me
know how excited you are in the comments
down below let me know your thoughts
what you want to see from Deadpool 3 and
what you want to see from Hugh Jackman
as Wolverine in the MCU and of course be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on Deadpool 3. Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and all the other MCU news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always catch me on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof